i went to uh i went to vegas and then
zion national park
and then death valley
and then back to vegas last night that i
was a muffler i woke up so exhausted
also quack quack hey okay the ducks are
quacking back
i posted some instagram stories
i was more active on instagram than
twitch like recently
yeah there were ducks and then this this
miniature horse kind of like a pony
wanted to play
anyway maybe i'll share
some pictures later but let's go back to
chess
playing aj
oh white moves first okay the e4
i was just thinking about the um the
fact i've never played a quaid variation
[Music]
of the king's gambit
i don't know if i'll remember it but
let's see if i can
something like g5
i think knight c3
wait a minute
i think it's knight c3 here
i might be misremembering
at some point lee chess calls it the
quaid
but i'm not sure
i feel like i already messed up
because this is a move
oh no my thing
wait how does this even work
i'm gonna have to refresh later
also i'm probably gonna avoid looking at
the chat because people
likely no better than me i don't want to
be spoiled
or have this line spoiled
so i'll just try and figure it out
um
yeah maybe i was supposed to play h4
first
i remember like white sacks are rook at
some point
i just don't know
[Music]
maybe this takes and then
okay we'll see if this
has any merit
i'm pretty sure this is the quake
variation though
takes
takes oh
black can do this
and i win the queen but i lose my rook
and black makes a new queen
oh
okay i'm pretty sure this is the main
trap of the quaint
if i'm not mistaken white's already like
completely winning
pretty sure knight d5
and 95 makes a ton of sense
oh thank you
for the game
additionally as the prophet foretold
quacker ronnie
amen
ah man
so i'm basing my memory off of it was
just like a
a minute or two
during the
beginning of the autumn marathon stream
where stephen gray
i could even show it like after this
game on youtube stephen gray was
explaining
like this cool line in king's gambit i'm
pretty sure i'm i've played it
to a t
also hi hi ross the boss gave me a
stafford gambit lesson on tuesday which
was fun
nonprofit website which has lines to
memorize while doing
studying
quack quack
welcome back
oh thank you silkyo7
okay so i should explain i was fighting
a threatening maiden one
um
black doesn't defend the pawn but
counter attacks my queen
and now it's a question
i mean i'm kind of tempted to play queen
h5 that hangs
that's just not a good move
also tempted to play this
where f7 and then c7 are both
still hanging
i mean queen f4 looks really nice
i should also calculate this
king d8
there's a funny line
i don't think it really works though
scruggling knight c7 king d queen f4
king c7 and i have a bunch of
discoveries but
most night moves are met with d6
so i think it makes more sense to play
queen
f4 first
and now
okay now if i get in knight c7 king d8
then
knight f7 would be mate
to attack the king while simultaneously
defending the knights
man this is such a fun position
and the problem for black okay even
though black is up a full rook here
this queen is stuck
i was gonna say the queen went in too
deep but it was more
uh the pawn turning into a queen
so this queen technically has not moved
yet
and yeah white should have like full
compensation for the rook
i guess okay knight c7 king f8
oh and then i oh i'm throwing mate in
two
yeah this is a real maiden two threat
so let's imagine this move
i take with chad king d8
am i meeting
oh this looks so close to mate
but maybe not quite
but it's really close
so i'm looking at queen f7 king d8 d3
just defending any queen e4 shenanigans
and then threatening bishop g5
and if oh no my knight bishop g5 knight
f6
uh
yeah i would just take take taking queen
e7 mate
or knight c7 with a a fork mate
yeah that would be faith
i'm just looking for better moves but
let's go with this
yeah d3 it's uh
not your typical forcing move not a
check not a capture but
okay it has a devastating threat to it
i just want to bring more pieces to the
party
yeah after this game i'm gonna have to
check the theory because i'm pretty sure
the position after
g takes age 1 equals queen
it's probably been reached like a few
hundred times
i have a vague memory of the engine
giving it is uh
like plus five for white
so the question is how does black not
get mated
because the king can't really run this
way c6 i still play this
and knight control c7
i mean maybe there's h6
it's still down a rook rook for a pawn
yeah imagining each six
would be really fun to like stack the
queen then f7 but
then there's king e8
oh
[Music]
oh i really want to play this move
because rook takes v8 knight f7 smother
mate
but okay queen eight there's uh there's
king takes
so it doesn't quite work
i mean i have bishop g5 though
which i don't think i can resist
any other options
i'm sensing some really like beautiful
mate coming up though
with the knights the queen the bishop
black's pieces are kind of
not doing much to defend the king
so i think rookie 8's only move
now where is my smother mate
and i wish we were playing the variant
where you could take your own pieces
knight takes f7 why is this not legal
the knight just wants to consume the
queen
uh oh there's this move
okay let's do this welcome back eric oh
good to be back
it's really good to be back
given the position okay so i'm threading
made in one
if black doesn't want to get mated the
rook has to move
back where it came from
but that's not gonna help
good afternoon from singapore
to replant the seed of the human plus
engine versus human plus engine idea
again
yeah thanks for replanting
but it's time to plant another seed
of a different type
oh no my queen
dot com
ah it's so satisfying
that was a really satisfying smaller
mate
that was two smother mates in a row
right because the previous game too to
see you in here again
hope you've had fun trip
oh i had lots of fun
and i can't stop sacking my queen for
smother mates
that's too much yeah i mean there were a
lot of beautiful moves
there was knight g8 someone saying in
chat
which would have pinned and threatened
queen f8 mate
though maybe it's not forcing because
the king can run
um
yeah real quick let's
let's learn something from this opening
so
it started as king's gambit
oh maybe before i actually dive in let's
see how
good my memory was
by looking at a recent youtube video
man i'm slightly overwhelmed by my
thumbnails
but where is okay the autumn marathon
so
in the marathon video
i have chapters
and one of the chapters i think yeah is
this one learning an epic king's gambit
trap
which i just achieved for the first time
i think
okay so we're going to relive the past
oh yeah okay steven gray
oh yeah e4 thanks to steven gray
ef4 knight f3
g5 knight c3 so this is what i just had
oh it's a quaint gambit
what two people on the chest do
wait seven or g4 okay let's do a little
bit of prep
ah so my opponent played g4
um which is a more like forcing
and more attractive move really for
black
uh so eventually i get to that
i looked at the bishop g7 line first but
g4 immediately 95.
wait what is this ah this is what i just
had
what is this takes
oh i can take on g4 okay
and now here i realized
two
am i discovering like the main trap
oh john davis plays this
ah yeah john i think john is a pioneer
in this line and the black queen is
reborn
so this was the first time i like became
aware of this this variation
uh thankfully i managed to remember it
so we got into that same position
um and
[Music]
oh g2 is just a losing move
which i'm sure i i realized like when i
was reviewing that uh analysis
because g2 just looks so natural
[Music]
most played almost 1200 times
and yeah black supple full rook
oh but i misplayed here i'm supposed to
play queen h5 apparently
what's wrong with knight d5
wait i'm losing here
wow
so black is doing okay
is g6 only move
only move d6
allowing
queen f7
and then the king's safe and i'm down
there rook and my knight's hanging and
my pawns hanging
i could have easily lost that game
oh that's fortunate
so i won the game in some beautiful
fashion and i learned a lesson
because yeah engine says i was losing
for a couple moves there
um
[Music]
so queen h5 is the only winning move for
white
idea being if knight h6 defending the
pawn
then d4
again only winning move
apparently d3 isn't as strong
i wonder what the difference is
so pawn is more
active on d4
and then d6
takes
takes so some engine line takes
now queen takes h8
ah pinnings when i hear
and now this is winning for white
engine likes this
let's say knight f8
and
material wise white's now up upon
with a great position okay d5 also
coming
okay
good to know
that was fun
my first quaid variation